وقبل سنوات فقدت العربيه واحدا من ابرز
مراسليها ومراسلي العالم العربي مدير
مكتبها في عمان سعد السيلان كان سعد رمزا
للتثاني حقيقه في العمل حتى اخر لحظه رغم
مرضه ومصدر الهام لزملائه في العربيه
من عمان مراسل العربيه عماد القضائي لعماد
انت ممن عمل مع المرحوم سعد السيلاوي تعده
ايضا استاذك في الاعلام ومن فتح لك الاثاق
عندما تستذكر يعني الزميل المرحوم سعد
السيلاوي ما ابرز ما ياتي الى ذهنك
محمد يعني ربما قصتنا نحن بالاردن مختلفه
نوعا ما عن باقي مكاتب في الاقليميه في
والدوليه ايضا في قناه العربيه التي يعني
جعلت من هذا من هذه المكاتب يعني نموذجا
لتصدير القصص ولاصدار القصص القصص القصه
عنا هنا في الاردن مختلفه ابتدات مع سعد
السيلاوي الراحل الكبير مراسلي قناه
العربيه عندما علمنا اول شيء ان الحرف
ممكن ان تنسج منه 100 كلمه وايضا يمكن ان
تنتج منه الاف القصص او مئات القصص علمنا
كيف نكون يعني انسانا قبل انك ان تكون
صحفي سعد السيلاوي بدات حياتي معه سنه عام
1995 بدانا حياتنا يعني بدات حياتي كنت
صغيرا في ذلك الوقت بدات مع مصور ومن ثم
قبل انتقال انطلاقه العربيه ناداني
وقعدت معه حكى لي انه هناك محطه اخرى
سننتقل لها هذه المحطه ستكون يعني عمليه
اكثر سياسيه اكثر وهي قناه العربيه قبل
اشهر من انطلاقه قناه العربيه لذلك يعني
هذا المكتب الذي انا فيه الان بدانا العمل
فيه من سنه الخمسه وتسعين بدانا بالتوسع
بعد ان يعني بدات قناه العربيه في عام
2003 امنا جميعا بان سعد السيلاوي ليس شخص
ورحل فقط بل هو فكره حاضره
يعني وتقليد هذه الفكره يعني واجب علينا
هذه الصور التي تشاهدها خلف محمد هي يعني
صور كبيره لكبيره للاستاذ سعد السيلاوي في
مراحله في اثناء يعني عمله في المقابلات
مع الزعماء مع الكل يعني ولكل صوره كان في
حكايه وروايه كنت مع المعلم الله يرحمه
سعد السيلاوي في رافقته كما تحدثت لك منذ
عام 1995 الى اخر يوم في حياتي هذه الحياه
التي كانت مليئه بالصخب والفرح كانت مليئه
ايضا بالجديه كنت معه مصورا ومن ثم بدات
معه في العربيه معدا الى ان اصبحت مراسا
لمراسلا لقناه العربيه امنا به جميعا وامن
بي انا يعني شخصيا بان اكون مراسلا لقناه
العربيه علمنا يعني ما هي الانسانيه علمنا
ان القصص الانسانيه اهم من كل السياسيه
ومن كل شيء علمنا ايضا يعني كيف نتعامل مع
الزعماء ومن ثم ننزل يعني ننزل الى الارض
والى الشوارع لكي نعمل القصص الانسانيه
التي تميز بها سعد السيلاوي يعني روحه
موجوده في المكتب لم يجب عن المغرب غاب
عنا جسدا ولكن يعني ما زال سعد السيلاوي
بفكره
يعني كل ما علمنا موجود في المكتب وسنستمر
ان شاء الله بهذه المسيره التي علمنا سعد
السيلاوي الجريء يعني اذكر بعض الحوادث
يعني اول ما يعني بعد سقوط بغداد دخلنا
الى الاراضي العراقيه وكان الوضع يعني
ربما من
اوائل المحطات التي دخلت
الى العراق كانت العربيه كان كنا برفقه
سعد السيلاوي وكان هو ايضا يعني المدير
الاقليمي
لمجموعه ام بي سي وكبير مراسلي قناه
العربيه في ذلك الوقت علمنا الجراه دخلنا
الى هذه المنطقه كانت الحدود العراقيه
الاردنيه كانت فارغه تماما لا نعرف يعني
مجهول الوضع بالداخل لكن دخلنا وكان له
يعني بصمه في يعني في بعض الاحيان اذكر
حادثه انه سقط او سمعنا صوت صاروخ كان
يعني بالقرب منا لكن
انا طبعا خفت وهربت من من هذا الصوت شو
حكى لي سعد بهذاك الوقت قال لي عماد الصوت
او الصاروخ اللي بتسمعه لا تخاف منه فقلت
له شو المعنى قال المعنى انه الاقدار بيد
الله واذا كان في اي شيء
يعني ممكن لا سمح الله بده يصير بصير من
غير ما تخاف لازم نطلع الكلمه ولازم نكون
واقفين امام الكاميرا لنقل الحدث كما هو
متميزا سواء كان في الديوان او في الميدان
هذا المكتب الذي تتحدث عنه بالتاكيد زورو
محمد
اكثر من مره في عمان دائما كان كريما سواء
كان داخل المكتب خارج المكتب واي صحفي
سواء من قناه العربيه او من اي قناه اخرى
يحتاج الى الدعم او المساعده كان سعد
السيلاوي يرحمه الله
لا يتردد ابدا في مساعدته وفي دعمه وفي
تقديم كل التسهيلات له كما عودنا دائما
رحم الله سعد
[موسيقى]